looking at it positives from the game
yeah I got my first
touchdown
yeah first
touchdown I mean at
Colorado
yeah you know first touchdown man felt
great but we still end up Lo we a end up
winning so was great in the moment but
after that had a shallow
route did my route and you know and did
anything I could do to get in the end
zone that's what I had to
do and that's when I spent move came
there you
know the camer SC me and Coach Prime
braing on my way back to the sideline
what did he say in that moment he didn't
say nothing he just said I love
you actually no he didn't he said uh you
know you got a penalty right I said oh
my bad coach
that's what I was after the touchdown
you said you know you got a penalty
right it's like my bad but yeah you know
we got to continue work can't get
penalties like that but yeah my boy
Xavier you know you know 10 did his
thing like always three
touchdowns
you know T gonna do his job got him
three touchdowns in
man listen right here I'm like oh my God
he is I put my hands up before he even
caught the ball soon as the ball went
there I put my hands
up yeah that was crazy
touchdown second was definitely a crazy
touchdown he just left
him there was nowhere to be found this
play we just worked on this
we were to play a lot in practice and it
ended up working in the game it was just
a Walkin touchdown it was
crazy everything happened that way was
supposed to happen everybody block who
it was supposed to block and what we did
it worked and that's what
happened yeah man did what I had to do Z
did what he had to do we just came up
short we did we got uh to
relax yeah I took a freaking hit on this
touchdown right
here I had I know I was getting hit
tried to ball up and turn away but it's
too
late took a hit not the win out of me
hit me R the ribs they kind of pick me
up nah could pick me I had to I had to
walk off under my own power you know
coach Prime you know if you can walk you
ain't hurt so get off the field so
that's what I did but that hit hurt but
I know I had to catch the ball no matter
what nobody care how hard I got hit long
as I call the ball that's all that
matter but I took a
shot that shot right there hurt worse
than my freaking cheap
shot
yeah that one heard about you
know get up and play nobody care